MICHIEL VANTHOOR:
Hey, everybody.
How is it going?
Had a good lunch?
So nice sandwiches, good
coffee, good drinks?
All set to go for another couple
of hours of awesome Google
Cloud technology.
So today, in my
session, I'm going
to talk to you about building
a custom chatbot with API.AI
and Cloud Functions.
So who has ever built
a chatbot before?
OK.
Who is planning to build one in
the next, let's say, 12 months?
Ah.
Obviously, chatbots are a
little bit the hype right now.
So I'm very glad that we had
this big room to go through it
with us together.
So my name is Michiel Vanthoor.
I'm a customer
engineer at Google,
based in Google Amsterdam.
And in this session, we
will cover three things--
the first one is the
basic building blocks
of building a chatbot.
The second one is
a demonstration
of how these building
blocks actually work.
So this will be the
exciting part for me.
And hopefully, also
together with you,
we can have some
working prototype
by the end of the session.
And then, last but not
least, Tim Daniels from ING
will share what they have
built the last six months
and also the lessons
learned along the way.
But, first, maybe it's a good
idea to take a step back.
So the people who were in
the keynote this morning
have already heard our
mission statement--
"To organize the
world's information
and make it universal,
accessible, and useful."
And if you think
about it, this is also
what we're doing
for Google Cloud.
So we're organizing your
business information
and make the
information you want
to share universally
accessible and useful
for your stakeholders, your
customers, your partners,
and also your employees.
What's maybe
interesting about that
is that we have
developed a lot of tools
for organizing information.
We have covered big data.
We're looking into
machine learning.
But the part I want to focus
on is making it universally
accessible.
This not only means making it
accessible across the globe
with low latency and
high availability,
but it is also mentioning
how people actually
interact with your information.
And that's where we
see a lot of change
happening the last few years.
So, traditionally, people
had to adjust to technology
to cope with it.
So people had to learn
to work with a keyboard.
People had to learn to work
with a mouse, stuff like that.
You can even go back to the
typewriter, where people also
had to learn to work with typing
and not writing or speaking--
the natural way of
people to communicate.
Obviously, around
2008, there was
this smartphone with this
giant touchscreen, which
enabled you to use gestures, to
actually use your fingers-- you
know, these tools
you use everyday--
to interact with the
world around you,
to also get something
back from technology.
And now, the third wave we're
seeing in this evolution
is the AI [INAUDIBLE] so that we
really can talk to the computer
like we do.
So the humans don't have
to adjust to technology,
but technology can
adjust to humans.
So we can just speak
like we normally do.
We can just write like a
normal written sentence
to get something
back from technology.
And this is obviously
where the chatbots fit in.
Through the advancement in
machine learning and compute,
we are now at a stage where
we are very confident in what
the technology can do.
And that's also why you
see a lot of activity
around this topic.
So let's make it a
little bit more concrete
and look at the
basic architecture.
This architecture is
both for voice chatbots--
so you speak to them,
like the Amazon Alexa,
Microsoft Cortana, or, of
course, the Google Home--
but can also be
used for textbots.
So if you have it
integrated on your website
or in your mobile
application, you
can use the same
basic architecture.
So the first one is
the user interface.
Then we have the
conversational agent platform.
And to fill it up, we
have the fulfillment side.
So we will go over
them one by one.
And later on I will also
show you how they work.
So the user interface-- this
is where your user interacts
with your bot.
This is where it will
connect with your chatbot.
Of course, in Google,
we like to think
that if people are
looking for information,
a natural way for
them to go is Google.
So we are investing a lot
in our Google Assistant.
It's available on Google phones,
on our Google Home devices,
but also on smartwatches
in your car,
so that you can be directly
in touch with Google.
You can also connect your own
chatbot to Google Assistant.
So you could say something
like, OK, Google,
let me talk to my chatbot.
And you will get routed to
the chatbot you've just built.
Of course, we also
know that not all users
are on Google all the time.
And they are also
on other platforms.
So we also want to offer
native integrations with that.
So think about Slack, Facebook
Messenger, Cisco Spark,
Microsoft Cortana,
or also Amazon Alexa.
And the third, but
not least, we also
want to have a software
development kit available so
that you can also integrate
in your mobile applications,
your websites, so
that you can have
complete flexibility on
how your users want to get
in touch with your chatbot.
The second building block is the
conversational agent platform.
And his job is very simple
but also very complicated.
He has to understand humans.
So he has to understand
something like,
can I get a pizza with
bacon and cheese--
make that a large one--
and oh, add some olives,
standard crust--
this very human way--
unstructured way-- that
people communicate.
So we, as developers,
of course, we
want to have a nice,
structured JSON format
where we can act upon and we can
do some nice applications upon.
But that's, unfortunately, not
the way most people talk to us.
And that's where we have to
find this conversational agent
platform.
And this is exactly
what API.AI does.
API.AI was a company we
acquired less than one year ago.
And it's one of the top used
platforms of building chatbots.
Just a quick poll--
how many people
are familiar with API.AI?
So I think that's a nice--
it's around 30% to 40% of the
room are already aware of it.
And I think if I ask this
question within one year,
it will be even more--
especially if you pay a lot
of attention in my session.
OK.
So we've covered the
two building blocks.
Now to the fulfillment side.
So once we've figured out
what the user actually wants,
we also have to make it happen.
And this happens on
the fulfillment side.
This is your back end.
This is where you
write your application,
like your used to doing today.
But, also, there on
Google Cloud Platform,
we have some very interesting
options to look into.
So the first thing you
can do is you can build up
your own virtual machines.
You can build up
your own network.
You can set up
your own firewall.
And you can really build your
application from the ground up,
having complete control
over your configuration
and your control.
The next thing you can do is
you can move a little bit more
to the manager averse, to the
more agile way of working.
You can use containers, where
the dependencies are already
concluded.
And you can run it in a managed
version, like Google Container
Engine.
So this is the
containers as servers.
But, of course, you
can also abstract it
a little bit more
further and only
concentrate on the
application codes.
Then you use platform
as a service.
And this could be
App Engine, we have.
For example, Snapchat
is using App Engine
to be globally available
for all their customers
across the world without
having to provision
virtual machines, provision
networks, only concentrate
on their core application.
And the most abstract
thing we have right now
is actually a Cloud Function.
So you don't focus on
the application level,
but you focus on
the function level.
And from there on, you can
sail how far you want to go.
So the more you go to the
right, the more no ops you have.
The more you go to
your left, the more
control and configuration
options you have available.
The App Engines on the
Cloud Function Zone
is what we call the
server-less zone.
This doesn't mean that there
are no servers available.
They're just abstracted
away for you.
And you don't have
to worry about them.
You can just focus on the code.
The scaling will
come automatically.
So if you have one request
or one million requests,
you don't care.
It just works.
And also, you only
pay for what you use.
So this makes it very
easy to get started
with it, to play with it.
And if it's a success,
you can just go with it.
The same story we
had at the Philips U
in the keynote earlier today.
So when we look at
the Cloud Functions,
specifically, they are
very perfect positions
for an event-oriented
architecture.
This could be
background function.
So, for example, if you upload a
file onto Google Cloud Storage,
you can trigger a function.
And you can, for example,
get some metadata.
You can use one of these
nice machine learning
APIs to get some metadata about
a video, or about a picture,
so that you can launch it.
You can attach it
to the storage.
This is also available
for Google Cloud Pub/Sub
and also with
Firebase integrations.
The other thing you can do is
you can make an HTTP function.
And then you can use
it as a web hook.
You can then start to easily
integrate it and use it as sort
of a glue for other APIs--
like, for example, the G Suite
APIs, but also with API.AI.
And this is where, of course,
the perfect fit is happening.
So this is the
basic architecture.
Is everyone clear with
the three building blocks?
Awesome.
So now I will go over
them in a demonstration.
I will try to build a Google
web store from scratch.
So bear with me.
We will go into this together.
And we will see
what we end up with.
The things I will
use is the API.AI
as a conversational
agent platform.
For the fulfillment side, we
will use a Cloud Function.
And then, on the
user interface, we
will see how it
interacts with Slack
and how that works in,
hopefully, under 10 minutes.
So let's get going.
[DING-DING]
OK.
Bear with me.
So the thing you see right
now is the API.AI interface.
On the left side, you have
your configuration options.
And on the right
side, you can directly
test it out and start
interacting with the chatbot
you're building.
In API.AI there are two
very important concepts
to be aware of.
The first one is intents.
The second ones are entities.
Intents are actions your people,
your users, want to execute.
And entities are objects
your users want to act upon.
So, in my example, I want to
make this Google web shop.
So I'm going to make
a product entity.
And I'm going to
sell, hopefully,
some Google Pixel phones.
And you see, you also have
the option to add synonyms.
Because people use different
words for the same object.
So I will also add pixel.
I will also add
[INAUDIBLE] Google pixels,
and pixels as well.
Next thing we want to sell
is, maybe, a Google Home--
Google Homes.
And people also call it
sometimes just a Home,
and a Homes.
We have a Chromecast--
Chromecasts.
And last, but not
least, the Chromebook--
Chromebooks.
And we've now created
our own entities.
The next thing we want to
do is make a first intent.
And you see there are already
two intents, default, in place.
So the first one is
the welcome intent.
This will be launched
when the user starts
to interact with your chatbot.
And the second one
is a fallback intent.
If API.AI is not able to figure
out the intent, it's a fallback
and it will guide the user
to the right direction
by maybe asking to
repeat the sentence.
So let's take a look
at the welcome content.
And you can say something
like, user says hi, or hello.
And then you can respond.
And you say something like, hey,
welcome to this awesome event.
What Google products
do you want?
We save it.
And now we can normally
directly test this.
So we can say, hi.
You see the default
welcome intent is launched.
And the response is, hi,
welcome to this awesome event.
What Google products
do you want?
So, of course, we also want
to make our own intents.
And if you're
running a web shop,
we're actually hoping that
people will buy something.
So we can make an intent
called buy product.
And the user could say
something like, hey,
can I buy five Chromebooks,
or maybe something like,
can I get three Chromecasts,
can you give me
nine Google Homes.
And what you see is
happening is that API.AI
is using machine learning and
natural language processing
to figure out which
entities are in place.
So it's figuring out,
ah, there's Google Home,
there's Chromebook,
there's Chromecast.
This is actually the product
entity we just created.
Next to that, it's also
figuring out the number.
So we can give a response
as well, say, like, sure.
And then we can use parameters
to refer to what the user says.
So we can say like,
number of product, devices
are on their way.
We save it.
And we can directly
start to play with it.
So we say, hey--
OK, the welcome
intent is launched.
Let's try to buy something.
Can I buy four Google
Pixels, please.
And what you see,
indeed, it's figuring out
the buy intent we just created.
It's figuring out the
parameters, the number,
and the product.
And it's launching the correct
answer we were hoping for.
So let's make it a little
bit more interesting
and maybe add the delivery date.
We call it dates.
And what you see is that API.AI
has a lot of entity types
already in place.
So you have dates.
You have geographic locations.
You have time zones,
all of these things.
And the one I'm interested in
right now is a date entity.
The next thing we
can do is we can
make these parameters required
for the intent to be complete.
So we can say, a buy
intent is only complete
if you have the number of
products, the actual product,
and also the delivery date.
So we make it required.
And then we can also
prompt the user.
If he doesn't give
enough information,
we can prompt
something like, sure,
when do you want the product
devices to be delivered?
We can add a response as well.
They will be delivered on date.
Of course, we save
what we are doing.
And let's try it again.
Can-- also something
interesting,
just for you to know.
So I trained to model
with Google Homes,
Chromecast, Chromebooks.
And in my example I was
using the Google Pixel.
So it's obviously smart
enough to figure out, OK, I'm
expecting an entity there.
You don't have to
give him everything.
This is the power of
these kind of entities.
I can also now just
add another entity.
And it will also take it into
account in all this training
that it's doing.
So let's write out-- can
I buy three Chromecasts?
OK.
So you see, at first
sight-- because I'm just
beginning to train
this model-- it was not
able to figure it out.
So it was asking me,
what is the product?
And now it's asking me,
when should it be delivered?
And we can say something
like next week, Monday.
And what you're seeing here--
I think it's very cool--
is that the system is
able to figure out,
OK, the intent is buy product.
The number and the
product are there.
And the date is an exact date
that we as developers love,
you know?
We, as a user, we just want
to say tomorrow or next week
Monday.
We want to act in a human way.
We don't want to
adjust to technology.
This is the point that
I was bringing earlier.
So, pretty cool or not?
OK.
Another thing we
can do-- so now I
showed you the conversational
agent platform, how that works.
But we also want to have
this fulfillment side,
this back-end side.
So if people actually
buy something,
you also want your
ERP system to kick in.
And you want to really
start something going on
in your back end.
So to show you that, I'm
going to make another intent.
And the way of
linking intents is
with another important
concept called context.
So if people are
buying something,
there is a chance that they
also want to do something else.
So we can-- after an end-user
has bought a product,
he is in some sort of a flow.
And we could call
this the buying mode.
What we can do then is we
can make another intent.
We call it add another.
And we can, here, insert an
input context also buying mode.
So the system knows that if
they like want something,
the user has bought
something, there's
a big chance that they also will
launch the add another intent.
And the user could say
something like, add another,
or, another one, please.
We save it.
And this time we're not going
to put the response into API.AI
but we're going to use the web
hook, the fulfillment side,
the third building block of
my presentation earlier on.
So the fulfillment is
configured over here.
It's one web hook.
It's my project name in
Google Cloud Platform.
And it's a Cloud Function
called fulfillment.
I will now show
you how this looks
like in Google Cloud Platform.
So, basically, it's a very
short function written in OJS.
It's getting a JSON
body from API.AI
and it is going to look
for the Action field.
And if the Action field is
something like add another,
it will get the quantity.
It will add one.
And it will respond
something like, here you go,
the new number of
devices are ordered.
You set the HTTP header.
And you set the status to 200.
You sent a response back.
And API.AI can
take it from there.
So now I want to make sure
that also the Action field.
So this is actually the
field where my Cloud function
is looking at.
So this has to be there.
And then we can normally
try it out again.
Let's go to the whole flow.
OK.
Welcome.
Can I buy-- maybe we can try,
can I order five Google pixels?
Sure.
When do you want the Google
Pixel devices to be delivered?
Today, of course.
Shortly it will be delivered.
And you see now,
again, the intent.
API.AI was figuring
out the intent.
It was figuring out
the good parameters
by having a conversation
with me as the end user.
And it's also giving, now,
this context of buying mode.
So API.AI is now
aware from, hey,
maybe this add an another
thing is something
that I can expect now.
So now, for the moment of truth,
at least two of my building
blocks coming together.
So let's try to add another.
And here you go-- six
devices are ordered.
Pretty cool, no?
[CLAPS HAND]
Ah.
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, it's maybe a little bit
stupid for this demonstration.
But if you think about
it, in just, I think,
less than 10 minutes, we were
able to have a fully scalable
chatbot working.
Of course, it still is
only a proof of concept.
But if you start thinking about
these kind of applications,
and you can really build
this inside your companies
to interact with your end
users, with your partners,
but also with your
employees, for example.
You can really already
make a huge step forward.
So a last thing I want to show
you is my final building block.
This was a user interface.
So here we have all the
native integrations available.
We also have links to the
software development kit.
Actions on Google-- I
believe that you will
know that this will be working.
So I want to show
you today's Slack.
Let me make sure it's turned on.
And then we go to my
API.AI bot in Slack.
And we basically say, hey--
oh-- let's do the one thing
in IT that always works.
Turning it off and
on again, of course.
OK.
I can also blame it
on Slack, of course.
No.
Hello?
[LAUGHTER]
Ah.
Welcome to this awesome event.
What Google product do you want?
Ah.
Now we're talking.
This one is still not
completely well-trained.
We can look into
this Chromebook.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHIEL VANTHOOR: Ah.
OK.
That's-- All right.
Ah, now I know.
I think I only said hello
in the training, right?
So when I was using this intent,
I was making this welcome
intent-- just for
your information--
I only trained it on
saying hello and hi.
And I was saying, hi, right?
OK.
I was saying hi with a capital.
So this is where
you have to train.
The model will
automatically train.
So what you will do and also,
maybe ING will touch upon this.
This is, of course,
machine learning
so it learns every time.
So you have to train it.
So you can say like, hi.
This should launch a
default welcome intent.
So you approve that.
And then the system is learning.
And you're making your
product better and better.
So that's where it takes
a little bit of time.
And that's where it's a
little bit tricky for me
to figure it out in 10 minutes.
But we will get there.
I want to buy
three Google Homes.
Today.
Add another.
Who actually has a good
Google Home at home?
OK.
So the one thing, like
once you have one,
you want to have
one in every room.
Because you start to get used
to saying something like,
turn my lights on and
turn my lights off.
So that's why another one
is a good intent you maybe
want to have.
And here you go-- four
devices are ordered.
[APPLAUSE]
So there you go.
I hope this was
interesting for you.
As you know, it's always tricky
to do a demo live on stage.
But what I did, I went
over these building blocks.
I started with a
conversational agent platform,
showing you how you can
input unstructured human data
and transform it into JSON,
and act upon it with a Cloud
Function.
We did the native
integration and Slack.
So it was only a very
short proof of concept.
I hope you can start
to play with it
and show it to your bosses
and show them how cool it is.
But if you want to
do the real work,
it's interesting to listen
to Tim Daniels from ING.
And they will share
their lessons learned.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM DANIELS: Thank you, Michiel.
And hello, everybody.
My name is Tim, and
indeed, I'm working
in a small but
enthusiastic team at ING.
And we are actively building
a chatbot for banking.
And what I especially liked
about the talk of Michiel
was that it brought back the
initial excitement we felt
when we started to use API.AI.
Now we are a couple
of months later.
And we still like it.
But it has evolved.
So it's a kind of journey.
And I will take you along--
the next 15 minutes--
along this journey.
But first I would like
to spend a few minutes
on why this is of importance to
ING, this type of technology.
So as we are in ING's home
town, I suppose that most of you
know that ING is a
global, universal bank.
And it has been a tremendous
focus on customer experience
the last few years and also on,
let's say, fostering internally
a real engineering culture.
And the reason
being that bankers
need to be where
their clients are.
And more and more, our customers
are on social platforms
or on other digital ecosystems.
So it's a very
natural thing for ING
to explore the
possibilities of chatbots.
And so here she is.
She's called Marie.
And she's what we call
your digital assistant.
And it's about six months
ago that we fired up
API.AI for the very first time.
And now, six months
later, Marie is
in production for a
well-controlled group
of customers and ING employees.
And as she will get
better and better--
because you need
users to train her.
So we train her,
thanks to the input
we get from the first users--
we will gradually increase
the group of people
that have access to Marie--
hopefully, until every
customer of ING can use her.
Secondly, what can she do?
She can help customers
with questions and requests
about cards.
Don't be mistaken-- she's not
a question and answer bot.
But she's what we would
like to call a do-bot.
She does things for customers
like ordering a replacement
card, activating
a card for usage
abroad, resetting a pin
code-- which sometimes happens
after a night out, as our
people in the contact center
know to tell me.
Initially, we have
spent quite some time
on deciding what the exact
scope of Marie should be.
And now, every day, we
are happy we did so.
Because having a clear
scope for your bot
saves you a lot of energy
along the way-- energy
you will need to cover all
the other aspects that come
with building a decent chatbot.
Maybe a last word on why cards.
First of all, cards--
it's about what you can do with
this tangible piece of plastic.
So in the people's heads, there
is a kind of natural boundary.
It's clear for people when
you talk about bank cards what
you're actually talking about.
And secondly, ING's still
getting a lot of calls
from people who want
help with their cards,
like resetting this pin
card, and so on and so forth.
Why we have chosen for Facebook
Messenger as user interface?
Well, simply because
it is popular.
As you have seen
with Michiel, it's
very easy to deploy
other channels as well.
Now, before I do the demo--
which I hope will work--
and then we will, after the
demo, we will also peek--
I will open up a
API.AI so that we
can peek into the brain
of Marie together.
And then you see, let's
say, a more extended bot
than the one of Michiel.
But before I do so, I would
like to introduce, briefly,
the overall architecture
of Marie to you.
And what you see is that
for the user interface--
that was simple.
That is just one component.
It's Facebook Messenger.
But the conversational
agent platform-- that we
have split over two components.
On the one hand, API.AI, where
we do all natural language
processing.
And that is important for us
because we want business people
to change what Marie is saying.
And therefore, we want to
have all natural language
generation, all the responses
of Marie also in one place.
And there is a second
component, which
is straight in the
middle, and therefore, we
called it the middleman.
And in that component we have
put some very specific logic
for us.
For example, we are at the bank.
If a customer orders
a replacement card,
we need to make sure that we
authenticate the customer.
And because the middleman is
in between Facebook Messenger,
API.AI, it knows at which point
in the conversation to start
the authentication flow--
authentication which we do
via a one-time password, which
we send out via Twilio.
Then, on the mobile phone,
the customer types it in,
gives it to Marie, and the
person is authenticated.
As you can see, we are
fully in the cloud.
So everything below
this thick orange line
are all the back-end
systems of ING
at 30 years of IT history
piled up in the cellar.
And above is all cloud.
Now we did it in the cloud.
And that is one of the
reasons that allowed
us to do it in six months.
Now don't be mistaken.
At a bank, security,
confidentiality, GDPR--
it's all important.
So we worked very hard
with our security officers,
our information and operational
risk managers, our fraud
experts, to make it as
secure as it needs to be.
So we are glad that
we did that with them.
And it worked out fine.
There are three other
components on the screen, which
is the sentiment
analysis API of Google,
because we're keeping
track of the sentiment
of a conversation.
Because if the
conversation gets too bad,
we want people in the
contact center to step in.
Therefore, we have the sentiment
and intervention dashboard.
And then, last, but not least,
Marie is talking English today.
And we're looking into ways to
make her quickly, let's say,
a polyglot.
Because in Belgium, you need
at least three languages--
four, even.
So we're doing some
experiments over there.
OK.
Now I hope-- because this is a
corporate laptop and there is
a demo with real
back-end interaction--
I hope it is going
to work out fine.
[DING-DING]
So can I have the
laptop on the screen?
Ah.
OK.
So you see, here she is.
The advantage of a bot is that
she is not nervous, like I am.
But, luckily, she
still remembers me.
Hi, Tim, she says,
which is important
for the personalization.
And for the moment,
only English.
OK.
Now I will tell it immediately,
I want to use my card abroad--
which was one of the use
cases I told you about.
And the funny thing is
that within a minute
I will need this
one-time password.
And I had put my phone
away because I did not
want to be distracted.
But I have to be distracted.
OK.
At first, we wanted
to use only text.
But quickly we learned that once
your customer is in a dialog,
please keep him there.
And then, visual elements,
like you see here--
it's called quick replies--
it helps a lot.
Now a debit card is a
more interesting case,
because there it depends
on the destination,
if the card needs to
be activated as well.
As you see, as well, Marie--
her responses--
Are not, let's say, flat.
There's a bit of joy,
there's a slight fun element,
which is the personality
of a bot-- something
you need to think about.
Now I'm traveling to Peru.
And she will ask me if she
needs to activate my card.
And I will tell her, yes,
that she needs to do so.
And she has sent
me now a pin code--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIM DANIELS: Yes.
Yeah.
Those are small things
we still need to fix.
Sometimes, let's say, that the
conversations are not all yet
up to standard.
Aha.
And now comes an
important element,
which is nice in, for
example, Facebook Messenger.
This is a carousel.
Instead of asking
the customer which
card, or what are the
last digits, and so on,
we show the cards a person has.
And then it becomes much
easier to choose one.
Now I had to enlarge
the screen a bit.
So I'm missing here--
because there should be
extra cards available.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIM DANIELS: There they are.
And so, as you can see, most
of the information on the cards
has been masked.
This is for security reasons.
Also, in the text
below, you will
see that we have applied
masking, because we do not
want Facebook to
know the numbers
of the cards of our customers.
They know that they
will have cards.
But that's not much information.
So I'm simply going to
tell Marie this one.
And then, like
Michiel already said,
this is quite
wonderful, of course.
Dashes, slashes-- you don't
need to worry about it.
Natural language
will just make sure
that you get where
you need to be.
Voila.
Now Marie will send--
she is now informing the
people at the back end
that they need to do something.
She has sent a
confirmation mail.
And that's about it.
OK.
Now let's have a
look into her brain.
And at this point in time,
we have about 150 intents.
So be prepared, when you're
going to build a real bot,
be prepared to have
a lot of intents.
We have about 10
full-fledged use cases.
I think half of the
intents are for that.
And then there's a lot of
stuff like small talk--
what are you wearing?
Where are you living?
How old are you?
Things people ask.
And you better have an answer
to that, otherwise they
think Marie's boring,
which she is not.
To keep strictures,
the dialogues
we have are all multi-intent.
And I will go quickly to the
use of brought one with it.
So you see that we are
applying a naming convention.
The name of the use
case is coming back.
And we are keeping
track of where
we are in the conversation.
And to make that
work, you really
need to get your contexts right.
So intents and entities
are very important.
But you will get nowhere
in a more advanced bot
without context.
So we are setting two contexts,
one for the overall use case,
and the second one to make sure
that the answer to the question
Marie is asking at
that point in time,
that that answer is
captured correctly.
So she's asking
for the card type.
So the outgoing context
is then about card types.
And then we have the intent--
if it's a credit card, then you
see this context coming back
as an input context.
Context is very important.
I am keeping, also,
an eye on the time.
So multi-intent
dialogues glued together
by context, which means that
the dialogue logic is fully
driven within API.AI.
So no coding there.
It's all configuration,
which we like.
Now I will-- because
time is limited--
and I will not touch
upon Cloud Functions.
This is a very rich topic.
And we are around
to talk about it.
But it's better not
to talk about it
than to talk too
shortly about it.
Now I will demonstrate
the last part, which
is our conversation dashboard.
Therefore, I will
get quite impolite.
So I will say, this
bot is terrible--
which I sometimes,
but seldomly, think.
And normally, she is a bit sad.
Ah.
Something--
[BELLS]
Oh, whoa.
OK.
So now someone in
our contact center
has been notified that a
conversation is derailing.
And for us it is very
important that people--
even if the conversation--
the automatic conversation--
does not work out,
that they leave
Marie with a good feeling.
So we can step into
the conversation, which
is a second major role apart
from our authentication
of this middleman.
So now you see here,
the complete trace
of the conversation--
like Facebook Messenger,
it stays available
for a long time.
And I can turn of Marie here.
And I can-- hi, Tim, from
the contact center here.
Voila.
And normally, voila.
So human take over--
this is very, very important.
So if I--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
So if you ask me-- at
the last six months,
you had a lot of fun
developing this bot.
What are your main takeaways?
And I would say, one--
make sure that you
have a clear scope.
And defend that against
the many stakeholders
you will get along your path.
Two-- make sure you master
the concept of contexts.
It's nontrivial, but
it's very powerful.
And it will allow you to
make multi-intent dialogues.
Then, as a third element,
think about the personality
of your bot.
Make it explicit.
We worked with
marketing for that.
And agree upon it.
And then, the fourth
element is, make sure
that your bot talks as quickly
as possible to other people
than those who are
building the bot.
Because, each time
we did it, we were
amazed by the
creativity of people
to say or to ask for simple
things in 1,000 different ways.
So you hand over the bot.
Then you see people going wild.
And then you think, oh, I
never thought of that utterance
and so on and so forth.
So you need about
30 to 50 utterances
for the entry intent, which is
the number we are striving for.
That was number four.
And number five is never
leave your bot alone.
And with this
concluding verse, I
would like to hand
the word over again
to Michiel for the wrap-up.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHIEL VANTHOOR: So,
thank you very much, Tim.
Very cool and interesting to
see what you are building here.
Just to wrap it up, we have
discussed some building blocks
first.
We were talking about
this user interface.
And there we said the
importance of being
cross-platform availability.
So you have these native
integrations as well as
these SDKs to integrate with.
API.AI-- very powerful.
And on the fulfillment
side, you have
a lot of options on the
Cloud platform as well.
Interesting to note, as well,
is that API.AI is for free right
now, the native
integrators as well.
And for example,
the Cloud Functions,
the first one million calls
or something are for free.
So it's really
easy to get going.
You don't need budget approvals
or something like that.
And then, when it works out,
like in the case of Tim,
you can easily
scale with demand.
One last thing I want to give
you before we wrap this up
is that we've covered a lot
of technical talks here--
demonstration and
technical insights.
But when you're dealing with
humans, like the marketing, the
how you deal with people,
becomes very important as well.
While developing our
Google Assistant,
we have learned
lessons along the way.
And we're also sharing
this with the community.
So also put some
considerable amount
of effort in this
interaction with humans.
So, basically, that's it.
I hope it was a very
interesting session.
We did the basic
run-through and then
the expert experience of someone
running it into production.
So I want to thank Tim again.
I want to thank you for your
attention and your energy.
And I hope you have a
very nice rest of the day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]